for the tampa bay rays here this
afternoon it's going to be right-hander
chris archer
runner
starting to stop and a swing out of his
donaldson strikes out second start of
the year for andrew albers at the big
league level third appearance overall so
far he has done a nice job
now here's a liner by a rosarena that's
going to roll all the way to the wall
deep part he could get three around
second on his way to third throw is not
in town head first a triple for a
rosarina
really one of the great contact hitters
in the game and juan
a base hit up the middle and franco
drives on the run
academic now
bronco
right back through the middle to get a
rosarina home
and wander franco who was out of the
lineup last night
first time up base hit driving in a run
into right field broncos going to be
waived home kepner's throw will not be
in time broncos scores standing up and
the raves out to a two-nothing lead as
diaz goes the other way to pick up the
run ban again
[Music]
center cut
drill to left and red snyder with a
sliding catch and left field two away
hannah
shot into center
buxton will have to go to his right the
rose arena is going to round third he
wanted to come but the stop sign goes up
by linares and it will be second and
third
oh and now
a bunk called
junior valentine calling the balk
we had this issue
in the first inning
and the reigns
will get a rose arena across the plate
franco will go to
third it's a three-nothing game
well here it is because he's pitching
out of that stretch
[Music]
there he goes he comes set
nothing really jumps out there you know
looking at that i'm
kind of scratching my head as well yeah
alvarez frustrated with what he was
hearing from
sam holbrook
and if you're rocco baldelli the last
thing you want
is a pitcher upset out there
with his concentration divided this way
there's a shot deep into left center
field that ball well tagged and gone
back into the runway
beyond the deepest part of the ballpark
and yandy diaz
has unloaded he has a three-run blast
and the raids have a six-nothing lead
luplow swings and sends a blast way up
into the air to left with ram snyder
back to the base of the wall
gone it just got over
luplow with a homer seven nothing range
back-to-back home runs diaz a three-run
shot luke lowe the solo blast let's see
if the rays can keep adding on the lead
at seven to nothing is and while margot
will lead it off
in the fly ball deep to left off the vat
of margaux that will go
home
manuel margot
number
and it's eight nothing tampa bay
[Music]
here's the fly ball
deep into right center and that ball is
going to get out home run the other way
for randy rosarino
and the raves had another run
to make it nine nothing a roger rada
with a triple and now a home run in this
game opposite field right center number
19. we're three innings into this game
and a rose arena all he needs is a
double for the cycle
runner now a third for kepler
third baseman diaz is
kind of right where you'd expect him to
be there's a ground ball in the first
and polanco comes in to score
and now the batter is going to be miguel
cino
to center and very deep and kiermeier is
just going to watch a
sail out of the ballpark so no hits his
24th of the year the twin strike back
with at least a couple in the fourth
inning
that was a rocket off the bat of miguel
cino right there
and now
it's nine to two here we go
we'll face cruz diaz and luplow and
raise up seven
that's a shot
deep into center
buxton will run out of room gone
home run for nelson cruz
number 27
and the rays make it 10-2 the rays have
hit five home runs
in three innings plus one hitter
five ball deep the other way grim snyder
will go back and that one is gone
an opposite field home run
for brandon loud his 32nd home run of
the year
and the bob
bartman continued i'll tell you that's
an impressive swing right there and some
kind of carry the other way here's a
tough out
and polanco lifts one high and deep to
right field and now he is a triple away
from the cycle
a long home run and the twins with two
more they get a two out hit of their own
this one was tagged a two run shot for
polanco his 26.
game moves into the
seventh inning peter kins will be the
third pitcher of the day for the race
down the third he has
on a nice backhand scoop by luplow
a one two three seventh heading for ends
seventh inning stretch time willian
ostadio will step in
ground ball short
bronco walls high throw comes down out
there and over to first
out there the race still get the double
play that's the ugliest 6-4-3 double
play i've ever seen
and they still make it work so with two
outs back-to-back walks to luplow and
walls
[Music]
weekly to hasta dea and he'll go to the
bag and wrap up the eighth inning
two innings under his belt he's in a
position to get a three-inning
save
that's gonna be strength three call
ryan sending a fly ball
left center
and that's going to be caught on the
track by rosarina
[Applause]
1-2
and there it is strike three call
and the rays are winners